on this episode the legend and I don't
sing that lately the legend Michael
Ovitz is in the building hey everybody
this is gary vay-ner-chuk and this is
episode 293 of the askgaryvee show and
this is gonna be one that I will watch
probably for the rest of my life every
Tues four or five seven years cuz I'm
gonna think of it very fondly I don't
throw this around very easily but an
absolute legend has walked in the title
this book cover I'm sure you're seeing
it for people listening on the podcast
google it who is Michael Ovitz is
something that we're gonna answer here
please Facebook I know you're watching
right now please put in your phone
numbers this is a rare opportunity
Michael is such an icon and mogul of the
culture which is what I appreciate and
I'll go into that in a minute but the at
this point of his career and all the
things he's focused on the ability to
ask they actually asked him a question
is far and few between so I'm excited
that our format is gonna allow two or
three of you to ask him a question and
as you listen if you know who he is I'm
sure you've got seven or eight questions
lined up but for some that don't as you
as we start putting down the blocks in
this episode I think you're gonna get
really excited Michael thank you so much
for being here thanks for having me for
for the people that are watching right
now that don't know who you are what is
the kind of two to three minute cliff
notes of who you are professionally
personally wherever you want to take it
um
someone who started out in the mailroom
at a large agency and went off with some
partners to start our own company and
started what I think to this day 40-plus
years later is the definitive Artists
Agency in the world and that is Creative
Artists Agency so for everybody who's
not from the Hollywood world or the
business world and you're playing in
your own silo CIA is a global leader
today Michael and his partners left
William Morris which is also a major
player now with an ax murderer WME in in
Hollywood land this is royalty you know
in every industry I came more from the
liquor business first and then
Kahn Valley culture which you've put a
big flag in and we'll get into that
later but if you if you're aware of the
LA business scene there are no bigger
businesses that have been built and in
the talent representation agency world
CAS at the top and Michael is really you
know I have so many friends who are
agents in in LA in New York and other
parts of the world and when I first
because of my wine show on YouTube
started having interest in that world
the amount of times I heard much you
know in the wine world not as much
though michael has a nice collection of
wine but as soon as I even sniffed into
anything that looked like representation
of talent in the world the name Michael
Ovitz got thrown around so many times I
was super intrigued and so many people
that I admire my contemporaries you know
really unbelievably look up to you you
really you know you know and I don't
know where you how you'll answer to this
but like you absolutely change the
paradigm of what a talent agent is and
was and to this day looked upon I mean
I'm not sure if it's really been
replicated is that something that you
think is great is that something that
you think is fabricated by the market is
that over a you know obviously somebody
who's an agent always wants to find that
balance between the talent being at the
forefront but you became very well-known
and a mogul and did incredible things
how do you how do you reconcile being in
a place in your life right now where you
can write a book called who is Michael
Ovitz and have it on the cover and just
have so many people know who you are and
the impact you've had to such a big part
I mean I think Hollywood Michael real
quick and I'll stop talking soon i think
hollywood is the great machine of
america I think America's brand in the
world is actually driven by the Machine
that Hollywood was and a lot of ways
Silicon Valley and social media is now
playing a little bit of that role but
it's kind of unbelievable that you were
top dog of the machine that probably
allows America to be top dog in the
world
do you ever take a step back and say
holy crap you know there's there's no
time to take a step back and think about
that
when I decided to write the book it was
more about trying to have some record of
all the stories and all the different
things that we did but to get right to
the heart of your question about what we
did when we started in the agency
business agents basically would field
offers for clients they would look they
would pick up the phone they'd pick up
the phone and someone would call and say
is Gary available for such-and-such a
day to do such-and-such a project and it
was pretty much a business that moved to
a pretty slow clock and we made a
decision while we were at William Morris
and watched this company which was
terrific a great company but suffering
from a disease that all companies do
which is lack of transition to younger
people with younger and fresher ideas
and the more senior people were running
the company and it was basically
stalling out and we came up with this
idea that it was really important for
the talent to be in the driver's seat
how do you do that how do you get the
talent from being in a second position
to being a first position and it was the
financers the buyers the studio's the
network's the publishing houses that
record companies all of whom were in the
driver's seat and we decided what we can
do is we would start to encourage our
clients to meet with each other meet
with other creative people and pretty
much keep all their ideas to themselves
in their group until we could take them
out completely hack it as a package and
by doing that over a period of years and
within a very short period of time what
period of time just four so we started
in late 72 cember of 74 officially
January 75 okay and it took us probably
it's is it true some like I've got
enough homework and there's been other
books and Google articles and
documentaries you guys were planning to
start a little bit later but then word
within W William Morris was heard and
this way you guys had to move quicker
yeah well what happened was I went to
the city National Bank which was a local
bank of oils for a $100,000 loan yes for
us to get started
and I didn't think that they would call
the treasurer of William Morris in New
York right and he called the CFO in LA
and he called the president they called
us you guys can leave which was moved
our plan yes yes we expect so December
January 74 75 by early eighties we were
in the position where we were selling
packaged material with all of our
clients and for everybody you know I
have a lot of people who probably don't
know all the Hollywood you know
terminology package would be like a big
star with a big director like like what
what are the pieces of a package in the
way that you guys created it to us a
package was anything that was built
around what we called a motor so you
needed one client who was a motor and
let's just take an example was an
example of a real package well real
package would have been a real package
would have been let's just take a simple
one ghostbusters
okay so Dan Aykroyd is not just a
brilliant performer he's a writer and he
came up with this idea about three
Saturday Night Live type guys running
around New York City chasing ghosts
okay and the one line just what you just
did you have to laugh yeah one line gave
the project two simultaneously to Bill
Murray and to Ivan Reitman Ivan who was
great producer director Ivan had done
stripes with Bill Murray and meatballs
he produced Animal House which was one
of the great comedies of all time and
bill nobody funnier than Bill Murray I
mean that sense of humor is beyond of
all time I mean beyond extraordinary so
bill and Danny and Ivan met and they
decided on Harold Ramis may rest in
peace it was from Chicago's second city
as a co-writer and the third Ghostbuster
and that put together a complete film
right there we had three stars
we had three writers and we had a
director and then you go to studio and
you reversed the leverage to the package
which made bids instead of going and
giving the IP exactly right
normally this studio would come to us
and say we have this script called
Ghostbusters and we want your story want
this story when I watched it well they'd
say we want this director we want this
writer and they'd come one step at a
time we came with the whole thing
completely put together for them all
they had to do is say yes or no that's
right and we did not give them much time
to say no how quickly did the rest of
the marquee so this packaging which gave
you guys a competitive advantage of a
new formula to go to market did the
other agencies quickly jump on board and
start doing it themselves or do they
kind of sit and push against it for a
while and then later succumb to it and
do it as well
well fortunately for us the competition
was slow to react and while they in
their inability to move quickly
audacity we started to sign it's what's
happening to vaynermedia right now in
the moments of their audacity while they
scrutinize it on land grant all I know
is in the two weeks since I've been up
here it looks like you have doubled and
so in their slowness in their slowness
we started to sign other clients and
once we had critical mass of a majority
of that was it was over because you
can't package without the elements and
we had three-quarters of the elements so
there was no competition and it was the
same problem for the studios they had
absolutely the ability to make contracts
but we had the creative people so what
we were trying to do was keep the
creative people working together and
hold their ideas until we could put them
together completely Facebook if you're
watching live now I know a lot of you
listening on the podcast or watching on
film but if you're watching now please
put in your phone number it's an amazing
opportunity to get a question into one
of the legends of culture in my opinion
obviously because as we keep going
through this what Michael was able to do
and disrupt not only in Hollywood he you
know I'm doing a lot of the talking bled
in by doing some incredible work for
coca-cola and other things and started
to describe Madison Avenue and now in
these days and we've spent less time
talking about this so I don't know as
much but spending enormous amount of
times in SF
with the contemporaries in Silicon
Valley so if you were a in my opinion
too because I have context to both the
audience and Michael's career and what
he's up to
if you were a creator and and you want
to ask a question and a macro and and
often if you're listening to watching
you know how much I talk about history
tells you the future I think there's no
better time to call now so putting your
phone numbers give Andy kind of your
questions and he's looking right now so
what happens next Michael so late you
know mid 70s you started this company
with two other and more than that a lot
of five lines later it could be across
the way it became kind of more core like
core three right after five right for
different reasons one of the guys
retired one of the guys kind of took a
little bit of a backseat but he stayed
with us yeah but it was really Ron Meyer
and Bill Hamer and myself and you guys
had a core run for quite a we had a good
run we had a good run it's really
incredible isn't it well what was the
biggest challenge of running a
three-headed monster
you know that's tough I always say to
cooks in the kitchen is already
difficult well I was really lucky I had
really good partners and we all split
things up in a really interesting way
yep so Ron was fantastic with the people
inside the company and also was great
with handling actors and actresses and
Bill no one better at putting television
shows together I mean the guy had this
extraordinary ability to read material
and ideas and be like and just
instantaneously figure out if he could
sell them as TV shows and that left me
an extraordinarily wide open field to
run so no one really stopped me from
doing anything and we had a different
idea every week of what to do a
different idea and these guys supported
it as a matter of fact when we came up
with the idea of working for coca-cola
and handling all their advertising
worldwide ad budget of over 600 million
dollars and their prior agency was
mccann-erickson they had 365 account
executives we came up with this idea
that we could do this and do it better
and we could do it for less money
and we could do it with six people and
bill haver came in as one of those six
people and we produced over 35
commercials a year for 10 years
including the polar bears which still
run to this day and we did it with
something that is known well today but
in those days didn't exist it's called
outsourcing and don't think what can I
tell you we were outsourcing animation
we didn't have to own all the animators
we're outsourcing all of the production
but our clients basically directed these
spots and we were doing 35 spots for the
cost of seven that's right we're being
done by the large agency and it was
incredibly well coordinated and Bill
spent an enormous amount of time on it
Michael let's jump through the book for
a second when is the book out tomorrow
amazing so it's out here today I'm very
excited about the seller son I'm better
flip this real quick on the internet for
a margin because people knows with your
jacket
exactly Michael what's the one story in
here that is either a clarification I
mean if such I mean guys I'm telling you
when you google whether it's Steven
Seagal whether it's like that there's
it's incredible the breath you know
what's amazing about what Michael has
done a lot of us have careers but we're
known within our industry what's amazing
about being a pioneer and at the
tippy-top and I'm talking number one of
Hollywood is like Ghostbusters
everyone's like Oh or like my favorite
stories of the old days is like which
actor almost was who right I think
you're Ron Ron managed Sylvester
Stallone is that correct so I remember
in some somewhere I heard that Sylvester
Stallone was almost Beverly Hills Cop do
you know about this I mean I don't know
what I don't know like I'm asking you
like it is there's truth to that right
there's so many movies but tell me that
one cuz that one to me when you think
Eddie as Beverly Hill cops and now
you're telling me wait sly was
strategically Iran or you or whoever was
saying this would be good for your
career because you're so Rambo and rocky
doubt this can show a different side of
you right just the thought that it was
this
close to sylvester stallone being
Beverly Hills Cop I think is fascinating
it is true but you have to realize that
these things there are so many films
that had different elements attached to
them and the elements changed I get it
and they change give me another one
Michael because I visit what I could sit
for like give me one like couldn't
because to me that's what everybody hold
people like literally in the comments
now
holy [ __ ] sly was almost like what's
another one in the 11th hour that the
actor changed out or somebody said no
and they regretted it for support
there's one on the book tell me
Schindler's List and Cape Fear where
Spielberg and Scorsese traded films the
Marty Marty developed Schindler's List
and Steven developed Cape Fear and wild
Steven wanted to do Schindler's List not
for a whole series of horse mostly
personal yeah Marty who is one of the
two of the greatest filmmakers in the
history of the universe both doing
projects that they basically decided
would be better if they switch projects
yeah like just looking at all your faces
and I'm sure it's good to me so so
what's storing here because there's so
many stories what did you either clarify
and/or what's a story in here that
nobody's heard before oh I couldn't even
answer that Carrie there's okay there's
there are so many stories in this book
that happened the book basically was
designed originally as ten deals was the
name of the book and that was ten years
ago and you felt that you could talk one
more time and that was ten years at ten
years ago so you thought through a
series of telling stories about ten
specific deals that you could help all
the entrepreneurs and executives of like
take the nuances from these ten separate
deals here's a complete package and a
blueprint for you to navigate and what
happened while I was doing it is that
the publisher kept asking for more
information and as I was working up in
the valley the the brilliant young
people that I work with the men and
women they were asking questions about
why did this work why did this not work
they were as interested in the mistakes
as they were in the
so I started to write more and more and
more and the stories went beyond the
deals they went into natural stories of
the creative process you know it's
really fascinating and you of all people
will appreciate this how do you define
creativity I will never forget and it's
in the book sitting in Japan I had flown
in I've been on a 13 hour flight went to
the hotel took a shower got ready went
to dinner which is the middle of the
night in LA went to dinner in Japan with
the head of Matsushita Electric and five
of his associates
I was with four of my associates from
CAA and in the course of me literally
having the most extraordinary time
staying awake I get asked this question
by this senior Matsushita official what
is creativity now that question is
almost impossible to answer but in a
strange way I tried to answer it or show
some peeks of it in the book how does a
film like Rain Man or Tutsi or
Ghostbusters or Jurassic Park or good
fellows how do these movies get put
together from a one-line idea that's
right so it's one line that's verbal and
you look down the road and three years
later you're watching it in a movie
theater I will never till the day I
disappear off the planet ever lose sight
of what an extraordinary privilege it
has been to be involved in that process
learn the process be involved with
people that understand the process and
it can actually transform an idea into
something you can read see or hear in
hindsight Michael that's that's amazing
in hindsight I really wanted to ask this
question and you're gonna you're gonna
play it off and be humble but I really
want you to answer it so please do this
for me what now that you can look back
on it you know and I think about people
I hate like Michael Jordan and Tom Brady
but this is more business like there's
there's this is what this is the life of
a 42 year old New York fan we just
happen to luckily be in the prime eras
of like these players that are our
competitors what in hindsight what did
it feel like to
we be at the top of the game of a game
of that size in those however you do I'm
sure everybody could define it
differently some may say was an 11-year
run a 3-year run a four-day run what you
know I'm not gonna allow you to dodge it
and say Gary I didn't never looked at it
that way you're it's inconceivable that
you didn't understand at some point holy
cow or I'm so glad I did it
this is what I set out to do that you
had an era where you were
disproportionately the most powerful guy
in Hollywood how does it do you feel
like now that you look back on it did it
just did you not realize it did it feel
like it was an over pressure like what
does it feel like to be in that in the
eye of the storm in the white heat
moment for a prolonged period of time of
a game that's so visual so first of all
you do feel it and you understand it the
question is do you believe it and I
never believed it
I feel understood it I understood it I
and I'll tell you why I understood it
because it's really a good question I
understood it because we had the ability
to get things done that no one else
could do right so when you have that
kind of Midas touch and you're what I on
what I call a positive role which is
that everything that you're touching is
working yes the amount of films and TV
shows that we put together yes we had a
15 year run that was unheard of and I
don't think I'll ever be duplicated I
think that's right
we package close to 300 movies probably
an equal number of television shows and
you've seen the list of the films
they're iconic now does that mean that
you let all that go to your head we
tried to basically handle it as best we
could but there are others around you
that may affect it that are affected and
there are people that write about you or
people that are jealous or people that
have been burned in the week that's
right of the power curve there's there's
frankly a lot of negatives that get
rolled into that great big positive so
for me I used to try to say to the staff
we have this giant Club don't ever ever
touch it don't even reach for it it's
gonna call it everybody knows that you
have we have this power to be able to
get things
made when we got Marty Scorsese's Last
Temptation of Christ made yes which no
one could touch or get done remember
that was the that and when we got Rain
Man made it it was a movie that
languished it was put into turn around
by Warner Brothers which means they
basically rejected it and said anyone
that wants it could have it we went
through four directors and ended up
getting at maintenance six Academy
Awards these kinds of things prove that
you have the ability the issue is there
are people in the wake of it sure the
collateral its collateral damage and I
must say the collateral damage was
bigger than I ever and the collateral is
multifaceted cuz it's not just
professional it's personal no it's
everything I think people don't realize
right it's not only your employees or
your competitors it is your spouses and
children and they're just there's
there's so much collateral with that
kind of white heat it's a sea of
collateral damage
and there's not much you can do about it
I don't know anyone that's experienced
the kind of run that we did that didn't
have the collateral damage and one of
the reasons I wrote the book is that I
came with the realization that it wasn't
so good that we had all this collateral
damage and I often ask myself could we
have done it differently and what do you
come up with in your own head nowadays
you know this is gonna be a not a
popular answer but could have done it a
little differently but not a lot yet
because I think I you know I apologize
for jumping in I'm gonna understand that
because as a creative businessman like
look the reality is I am Who I am like
like like I'm aware that I'm gonna be in
the similar realization I already am
about things that you don't what you
don't realize is that you're it's like
throwing a stone into a still water and
you have a series of concentric circles
you don't realize that you're the stone
yeah so it's not the first concentric
circle that's an issue or the second or
the third it's the one way out there
that you don't know exists and there are
people that work for you and they're all
out here they're speaking for you a
hundred percent
they don't all say the right thing
I default the other way I'm really I
mean it I think the only the way I tried
to thoughtfully think about it over time
is I default into when they are saying
the right thing I'm you just can't
control certain so we tried hard to
control it yes and that's why we
reviewed as controlling and we were
viewed as having Stepford that's having
Stepford agents hello Niki its Gary
Vaynerchuk you're on the askgaryvee show
with michael ovitz
what's your question thank you yeah
that's a good idea basically I just
wanted to ask with being with Creative
Artists Agency what's something that
when you work with a lot of other people
kind of high-profile that you don't want
them to do that you're like oh this is a
mistake they made they could have had
been my client but yeah you mean
something you did you don't want them to
do like what's a mistake that when you
have artists who want to be your client
something that they do that prevents you
from saying yes to them oh you mean you
mean the other way where when you're at
the at the top like a CIA
what would a emerging actor actress
director athletes say that could
actually turn off CIA from saying you
know what you're not the right client
for us is that the question correct
interesting that's what you know I've
never you know I think it's funny that
both the you and I reacted that way a
lot of people talk about be thoughtful
about what you know my team very senior
people lots of great people we have to
be thoughtful about who we bring in they
need to be the right kind of client I'm
like yes yes yes you know it's funny
that we both reacted that way so have
you ever had a meeting where you were
court let's go this way
because I'd love to hear it play on that
question
did you ever court somebody because
you're like oh my god that would be a
crown jewel
would that be a big get for the firm and
I know you went whale hunting was there
ever as you were whale hunting through
the years when you actually got closer
to it you said oh [ __ ] she or he is such
a headache or they have this
vulnerability or or somebody in our
stable has emerged as a direct
competitor and we don't have the
bandwidth was there ever to her to her
point was Rober any of that yeah we we
had one situation which was really
difficult for us which is we as you've
already mentioned we handled Sylvester
Stallone and he was very competitive
with Arnold Schwarzenegger and Arnold
was somebody that I really wanted to
lose him yes he was them first of all
he's the most terrific guy yeah he's
really smart and he really understood
the paradigm of the action movie is
better than anybody if you look back at
his body of work yes pretty amazing and
I went after Arnold and wanted him and
it got back to sly and he wasn't
particularly happy and that's not that
was that is there a reason you're asking
that question are you going through a
path or anything like you're trying to
navigate well the reason why I asked is
because I feel like as someone who's in
Los Angeles and is you know along with
thousands hundreds of thousands of other
people what is it people always ask Oh
what should I do to get into the door
and so I was like is there something
that I shouldn't do to what I'm trying
to get into the door because it seems
like everybody has an answer for how to
get into the door but not like hey make
sure you don't do this
you know I think short of anything is
building I think anything short of
illegal or immoral you should do
whatever you feel you have to do to move
your career ahead we didn't we were
lucky we went after talented people and
at the end of the day talent wins out
always and I think it's it's when you're
young you have to look for breaks you
really have to look for breaks and they
may be social they may be business they
may be because you've got an idea let's
not forget we spoke about Stallone this
guy wrote a script called rocky it's
back on spec on his own dime and sold
his damn dog everybody wanted
by that script and move him out of it
and to his credit he said no me no
script and that's hard when your home
started it's really hard and we do a lot
of a lot of guts to do that because he
was offered a lot of money for that
script the thing that's different today
than some of those years past for sly or
when you were at CAA is people can now
go direct to consumer you can now
produce content and use the distribution
of an Instagram or YouTube or a podcast
to absolutely give you leverage to be
courted in a very interesting way in the
way that you created packaging with
leveraging the studio's the human can
now create content to build leverage to
have people bid for them absolutely I
mean that's what happened to me by the
way real quick my little quick CI
stories I started Wine Show on YouTube
in 2006 and July of 2007 after showing
up on Conan on late-night because the
producers reached out to me because they
were watching it on YouTube the next
morning I had an email from endeavour
before the merger William Morris others
everybody Byronic Lee but CAA then said
on my show that I was going to Hollywood
to find an agent it was like this funny
joke because I thought it was crazy and
then I got an email from some people
that worked at CAA they were having a
fantasy football draft that day and they
and they said why don't you come and
hang out with us I didn't I said yes but
they didn't say they were from CAA they
said what are you doing here I said I'm
going to see these Hollywood agents they
said are you gonna see CAA said no and
they made it happen and that's who I
ended up signing with that was all based
on me producing a wine show in a store
in Springfield New Jersey there was no
moving to LA and waiting on tables and
going to auditions we have an incredible
world we live in now where you can
create the leverage for you on the back
of the internet different different time
completely different in our day there
were roughly 25 companies that
controlled the complete gate in other
words the barrier to entry it was severe
you had seven studios you had four
networks you had five publishing houses
you had five record companies and
probably you know ten companies in
Europe that controlled everything that
you would read see in here our company
had relationships with all these
companies at the end if you were a
client you got in the door if you
weren't a client you you have trouble
getting in the door today this person
that called in if they could make
something three minutes long using their
iPhone or a small Sony camera they could
put it up and if it went viral good god
Kiki do you love me the dance he's in
great Shakey's in Drake's video four
months later one video on Instagram it
goes I mean just incredible time it's
the only song my three-year-old grandson
wants to hear brad has the same Michael
then we'll go back a little bit into the
book good afternoon this is Brad Brad
this is Gary Vaynerchuk and you're on
the askgaryvee show with michael ovitz
oh my gosh i'm having an out-of-body
experience that is a very good thing my
friend thank you so much for taking my
call no worries what is your question my
friend well I know that mister Ovitz you
had a tough slog with Disney that ended
poorly just wanted to get your comments
on what lessons you took from that that
session don't go to Disney now that
doesn't include the theme parks I happen
to like them know was as I said in the
book it's the biggest career mistake I
ever made I completely misjudged it and
it's a it's a really good example of how
and why not to be your own counsel and
and you know it's funny you brought that
up once when we first met about not
being your own counsel and the value of
why we're sitting together for everybody
at home just give him the one to two
minute cliff notes obviously the three
of us know what we're talking about but
I think would be fascinating for
everybody at home what is the Disney
chapter the Disney chapter is about
starts with my set of meetings with
Michael Eisner yes it goes through the
time when he had a heart attack
and I stayed in the hospital with him
for five to six days and he asked me to
come on board to originally be the
co-ceo and
that went back down to being the
president/ceo Owen and then it went to
be the president and then when I showed
up at his house for our first meeting
prior to starting all the people who are
supposed to report to me he decided
weren't in a report to me so it was kind
of over before it started yeah and did
he know that at that point I had well I
knew it the minute that point you know I
knew it when I was sitting in his living
room at his house when the when he had
the CFO and the chief legal officer
there and he they said they weren't
gonna report to me and he didn't do
anything about it he said okay well I
mean if he was the CEO that really
wanted this to work I get it and he
wanted a partner I mean what we were
trying to do was set up a partnership
the way Bob Daley and Terry someone had
at once or Don kilo and Roberto boys at
a Coca Cola I understand or Tom Murphy
and Dan Burke at ABC cap cities these
were powerful partnerships these were
big companies Disney was about to buy
ABC it was going to be a behemoth
company more than one person could run
so the concept was to create a dynamic
partnership understand thanks for the
call brother quick question what do you
know about Okanagan wine I know that the
Pinot Noir from that region super
intrigued me like right before I made
the transition to Silicon Valley from
the wine world I thought that the that
British Columbia and Vancouver was an
Okanagan region specifically was make
were making wines that I thought were
world-class but nobody knew how to
market them in the same way that I look
at Baja California Mexico I think the
two best wines in the world that nobody
knows anything about are Okanagan Pinot
Noir and Baja California Cabernet is
from Mexico because if you roll up on
anybody and talk about wine Mexico and
Vancouver are not coming out of their
mouth so what I know about them is
they're obnoxiously high quality with
absolutely no brand awareness it got and
I thought Okanagan was in Japan I know
they're big you you know you're you know
you love Japan huh like that's it like
do you still do you go there often
I haven't recently but I used to go once
a month once a month once a month you oh
man I want to use the final time for
Michael I have so many entrepreneurs
young entrepreneurs we're all ages but I
know the base of who's listening to this
show a lot of 15 to 35 with plenty older
but like what's at this point as
somebody who spent the last decade plus
in Silicon Valley culture and all those
leaders obviously la just a you know a
man of the world with Japan in New York
and just you've played it you've played
it at the highest levels for the last
three four five decades like what what
do you think is the universal things
that people should be thinking about
regardless of the internet not internet
regardless of the time no networks
unlimited networks with the internet
what are the traits or the
characteristics when you know what
you've had is a really amazing first I
view into both creative and business
Titans that have been able to be
successful it's not just you know that's
what's so beautiful about the business
you had and much of what I like about
Vayner it's then I get other views into
the world you've had that at the highest
levels are there a theme or two of
individuals that are able to succeed or
is there anything that stands out it's a
great question nothing has changed for
me from the day I started in the
entertainment business through today
when I work up in the valley between San
Francisco and San Jose it is all about
the person 100% all about the person
nothing else matters to me they could
have an idea that you think is good if
the person's great invest in the person
maybe their second or third ideal be
better than their first but it's all
about give me a historic story in pop
culture and I think we'd all enjoy that
you so believed in the person where
their first idea wasn't as strong and
the second one was they made I don't
know transformers you know whatever well
you can frankly look to almost any
director and the early work yeah you
know but you you you you look at their
early work it doesn't look anything like
their mature work or you look at some of
the actors that started out I mean
Sydney [ __ ] who is a great director
who was very important to see a started
out as an actor and frankly
he wasn't a great idea when he started
out he started out with Redford and
Redford turned out to be a better actor
and Sydney turned out to be an
extraordinary director who then became a
great actor and if you remember his
Roland Tootsie where he played the agent
which I thought was really kind of funny
since I got to coach him and everyone
starts out slow and the careers that to
me are the best are like trains coming
out of a station no ma'am I am not big
on instantaneous stardom I don't think
you think it's a vulnerability I think
it's a huge following because there's
nowhere to go but down can you think of
an example of somebody who's able to
calibrate instant fame and then build on
top of that over time does anything come
to mind when I say that I mean I think
of like I don't want to comment on
anybody's career per se but I will say
that in the music business it's a big
game yeah one-hit wonder I was the first
song yes it happened so fast
it happens fast they come and go and
it's really unfortunate
you know we were in the business of
building careers Gary we were in the
business Americans well we we were in
for the long run
yeah you know when you meet Tom Cruise
at 19 you want to make sure that it
lasts especially when you believe in the
person you don't want to have somebody
flame out quickly and by the way with
bringing up the point that you raised
when you look at today's world with
instantaneous communication and 5g
around the corner oh my god it's just
too easy to flame out you know what I
love about you that I have so many
people I interact with the fact that I
believe that 5g is one of the most
outrageous technologies that are here
this is not like wait to what have you
and the fact that so few people are
bringing it up in fact that you drop
that subtly in this interview is like I
personally enjoy that I tend to do
things like that make references to
things like do you believe that anybody
like are you stunned by how few people
understand how big of a technology
changed 5g is gonna be over the next
couple years what I'm stunned by is how
few people in the world really have
grasps that changes the technology are
bringing
now beyond what they think they think
they're big but they're humongous and
when they start looking at what's
happening coming down the road 5g is the
tip of the iceberg yeah let's get into
AI sure it's a whole different game
hundred percent I mean the applications
for this are beyond comprehension
particularly to businesses that are
stratified businesses these businesses
these big businesses the fortune 500
companies this has got to be at the very
top of their agenda of priorities yeah
but it's not because everything is Wall
Street dynamics and they're trying to
maximize margin there ninety days one of
the things I learned early on is don't
think in quarters and I learned that by
traveling to Asia in the 80s don't think
in quarters start thinking long term
watching how different cultures react to
different things the other thing I
learned in Asia which was great is have
some respect for your elders and now
that I'm an elder I'll do you like that
much more now what parting shots what
did we not cover in this session that
you'd like to talk about or anything
that's on your mind or things that you'd
like people to think about no I don't I
think you've covered pretty much
everything I mean there's a zillion
stories in The Naked City it's right now
and I've got a lot of stories in them
let me ask one then thing this the four
to seven to eleven people that you gave
this book to already that have read it
right these are clearly people that have
been your friends for 30 years or a
family member what is what's been the
feedback you've gotten from this book
that either feels best and or is most
surprising that you didn't see but three
people have commented on that already
well the the person that I gave the book
to through the whole writing of the book
is the person I live with end tomorrow
Mellon and she's the one who would say
to me your phone really stinks you know
this is awful this is the person who I
trusted yes she's been pretty positive
on the end result and how's it feel the
day before the book are you excited I
mean you were you know am i correct like
you you not explode but you you had some
like you were very interested in the
publishing game back in the day and like
you saw a lot of opportunity in that
space that other people
see I we represented usually half the
New York Times bestseller list on a
weekly basis somebody who sat on the
other side this has been the most
bizarre expanding with when I started
talking to you yep I told you that when
we talked yeah this is insane I planned
the publicity trips I planned all of the
different shows that people would do I
would supervise anything that the big
authors would do yeah and I would
sometimes sit in when they did some of
the interviews I find this to be
absolutely hysterical that I'm on this
side of the table I can't believe it
if you're watching I highly recommend
you pick this up on Amazon at your local
bookstore I have a very funny listen a
lot of you know my spiel I'm
unbelievably passionate about history
telling you the future and when you get
to see players play it at the highest
level and articulate especially in
storytelling form I know that this
audience especially how it reacts to me
picks up on those nuances I think this
will be extremely beneficial to a lot of
you whether you know Michael deeply or
don't know him at all I have a funny
feeling a lot of you'll appreciate it so
pick it up support this man and thank
you so much now question of the day this
is our thing for every guest you get to
ask the question what is your question
to the vaynernation my question is
pretty simple we have we are in the
middle right now of audience viewership
change yes and it is we're dead center
in the middle of it we come from a world
at least I do where we watch things day
and date and now we're in a world where
everything is streamed on-demand present
and I want to know what the audience
thinks of this new change and what it's
done also to the unique film the
uniqueness of the film business with
television and the on-demand world has
kind of taken the spark out of the film
business yeah I think that's right
Michael thank you so much my friend you
keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
[Music]